crash test executing in 3 2 1
[Music]
so this is our crash test barrier lab
the test vehicle starts at the end of
the track about 340 feet away we attach
the vehicle to the propulsion system to
the steel cable here the two Model S
performance drive units will be in test
vehicle all the way down the track until
it's about three feet away from the wall
well in advance of us ever producing a
physical prototype
we're running thousands of crash
simulations at the design level will
produce 3d models of the parts and will
simulate those using very complex and
sophisticated mathematical models that
represent the physics of the crash
[Music]
one unique passive safety feature in the
model 3 is especially designed front
passenger airbag which helps protect the
occupant in oblique crashes where they
might come in contact with the interior
safety is is a top priority so I think
that's really encouraging when you see
feedback from people that have got into
serious crashes and they give you that
feedback that you've saved their lives
or the lives of their loved ones is a
really great feeling and shows the work
that we're doing is worthwhile
[Music]